Please welcome Steve Chant to Google.
Okay.
Thank you very much for us.
So I'm going to be talking today about some work that was done with the European
Space Agency.
A,
I want to emphasize,
I,
this was all collaborative work.
Uh,
uh,
with Isa,
at the top of my team is at the top of this.
Here is where my team,
including myself,
Greg gravity or Danny Tran,
Martinia tuition,
Josh Double Day.
Uh,
the rest of those lines are actually all a ISA collaborators of mine.
I'm the operations engineers.
Federico Nespoli,
Miguel Perez,
I car mark Costa.
See Day,
uh,
as well as liaison scientists.
Claire have a lot.
Bernard Geiger,
um,
uh,
Nico Altobelli and the software team,
Manuel Fernandez,
friend Valeho,
a Rafi Andrews and Michael Coppers.
Uh,
so I have to emphasize very strongly this has been a collaborative effort.
So I'm going to start off by talking a little bit about comments and why we're
interested in comments and why we want to go there.
So I'm going to start with a video here in this video is actually very good
cause it's technically accurate.
It's quite unusual was set to spacecraft
landing distance comments 60 71 thing here to remember is that,
compare the pictures of the comment here during this VR video,
which is before we got there,
the web,
we actually couldn't,
comments are really important.
They're like a time capsule back to our past were formed just as the planets
performed in solar system formation.
This is actually accurate with the planetary,
just the formation of the solar system.
Did that,
is that the original material that the solar system kind of went from something
like that to water and oceans and palm trees and the light?
How do we know what our original solar system was made out of?
Does the comment really represent some of that original material?
And it's so very different.
How do we get from there to where we are now?
So actually,
uh,
there were a few things that were probably in their video.
They were a little too fast going by.
But uh,
early on before the solar system really existed between four and four and a half
billion years ago,
there was just a ball of gas,
gas,
dust,
ice.
And so on.
And because of conservation of angular momentum,
it begins to form into a disc.
And that disc,
the elements in that disc are,
are what are called plan and testimonials in common testimonials.
And so they,
as they come,
come together and they collide and they hit,
they stick together.
Uh,
and so generally,
very slowly,
everything forms in.
Eventually it becomes the planets that we know.
And the problem is if we look at on earth,
the different materials we have there too distorted the,
there two evolved in mature from a,
from a,
uh,
a solar system formation standpoint.
So what happens is when we look at the things on earth,
they've been affected by water.
They've been affected by the sun.
So they're not like the solar system was four and a half billion years ago.
Comments are actually the enable us to look back into what the solar system,
this was like over 4 billion years ago.
And the way we do that is we have to go and find these comments in.
The comments exist in two main areas,
the Kuyper belt and the Oort cloud.
So the Kuyper belt you might know about because,
uh,
Pluto is no longer a planet.
It's just one of many,
many Kuyper belt objects.
So that's the primary near source of comments.
And then the Oort cloud,
I didn't know this before I started working on Rosetta is much further out.
It's so far out,
it's about one quarter of the way to the nearest star.
So it's really what some people might consider interstellar space.
And ideally what we'd like to do is we'd like to go out into the Oort cloud and
take one of those objects and study it.
But shockingly,
going a quarter of the way to the nearest star is kind of hard.
So that would take a long time and a lot more money.
Uh,
let's suppose the next best thing you want to do,
you want to find one of those objects that's coming into the inner solar system.
Uh,
so those of you who remember,
remember your physics would know that,
uh,
if you have something that's in,
as eccentric of an orbit is that its angular momentum is going to be conserved.
What does that mean when it comes in?
It's going to be going really,
really fast.
Okay.
The other problem is it's period might be hundreds of thousands of years,
so you need to find this dark object,
which is one light year away.
You need to predict that it's going to come in and you need to predict this by
the way,
about 15 years in advance because that's how long it takes to build the
spacecraft and plan the trajectory to meet it.
So kind of hard things to do.
Okay,
so now,
now the,
what's the next thing we're going to try and do?
I'm going to try and get a Kuyper belt object.
Well,
it turns out that there's what are called Jupiter main belt comments.
These are comments that were in the Kuyper belt and there were perturbed at some
various point in time and so there's sort of in the orbit of Jupiter that's kind
of good,
but Jupiter is kind of hard to get to.
Also write
[inaudible],
which is the target that we had for,
for Rosetta is actually a main belt comment and the extremely impressive nab nab
people figured out that about in the 18 hundreds about 1850.
It was perturbed from a 10 year orbit to a six year orbit.
And then from that time period it was perturbed again in 1952 an even shallower
orbit.
And since that time it's been coming into the earth.
Okay.
And so,
well,
coming in near the earth coming into the earth would be a very bad thing for all
of us.
Uh,
so we have this comment that's only 50 60 years been coming in and having all of
these volatiles burnt off of it.
So this is a great target for us to,
uh,
rest to get to visit.
So,
uh,
well originally,
originally it was,
so the question was what was the path before?
So it's originally as a main belt comment.
Then it was perturbed to have a roughly one decade or a bit that still did not
take it close enough to the sun.
And then it was perturbed into this six year orbit.
And I think I actually messed up the dates around 1950 uh,
and then since then it's actually been in this six year orbit and since it's
period is 6.6 years,
you can do the math and figure out how many times it's had the volatiles
disturbed.
Does that answer your question?
Okay,
great.
Still it's quite hard to get to this comment and why?
Because when it's in this highly eccentric orbit,
it's going really fast relative to the earth.
So we actually launched,
Rosetta actually launched in 2004 and we had Mars earth,
earth,
earth.
Okay.
So we've been flying over a decade to try and catch this comment and you said,
wait,
you told me the comment only has a period of 6.6 years.
Yes,
that's right.
We've been flying so long to match with this comment.
We missed it the first time around and we're catching it the second time around.
And this is actually entirely accurate here.
We chased it to actually chase it from behind to arrive at the comment,
uh,
way far out there.
That outer line is in fact Jupiter.
So now you can look at,
you know,
Jupiter versus in Earth orbit.
Uh,
and then we followed it to a pair of Helion,
which was August,
2015 and so this is really a fantastic chance to visit this comment because we
chased it,
we caught up with it and an orbit.
And August,
2014 we sought to the closest approach and then an additional year we saw it
cooled down and become less active.
So just to put this in a little bit of scale,
in 2004 when Rosetta launched,
this was your cell phone.
Does anybody here have a flip phone still?
Okay.
The top pop artists was Brittany Spears.
And this last one went over quite well at Harvard.
Some undergraduate started a company in his dorm room called the Facebook that,
and we'll just leave it at that.
Okay.
So where is that?
ETA is really one of the most challenging space missions ever conducted.
So 6 billion kilometer crews for over 10 years.
As we talked about.
And you know,
all of the four gravity assists a two and a half year hibernation.
So originally they had a different target.
They actually had a launch vehicle problem and they had to adjust to this
target.
So for two and a half years,
the spacecraft actually was existing just on heaters in batteries and a timer in
the,
in thermal points to wake it up,
went out to 5.2.
We Aau in Aau is of course the distance of earth to the sun.
So about 93 million miles.
I'm an American,
so I'm not so good at the metric.
Uh,
correction rendezvous with a four kilometer object traveling at 135,000
kilometers per hour.
And then this slide is actually a little out of date.
So normally we only went about 10 kilometers,
but since last week I can say we went to zero kilometers since the orbiter
actually landed on the comet.
Uh,
but before that we flew fly bys of about two kilometers orbiting a changing
common environment.
And I'll tell a little bit of a story about how the spacecraft safe one time
when we flew to closely,
uh,
and unknown landing environment.
We'll talk more about that later in orbiting a low gravity body.
Just to give you an idea of the scale of there's Ed admission,
26 instruments on both the Landon Landon orbiter,
uh,
over 2000 people worked on the project.
And of course the only thing that we can really relate to is the total costs
about 1.7 billion US dollars.
That figure obviously changes with exchange rates.
Um,
so NASA was quite thrilled to be part of this east submission.
I have to always emphasize it's an east submission.
Uh,
and specifically Rosetta is really the truest sense of space exploration.
And I'll talk a little bit about some of the things that we learned about
comments that if you'd pulled all the commentary scientists before,
they would have all been a hundred degree,
180 degrees in the opposite direction before.
So recall the earlier I sh in the video I showed you this round,
mostly your spiritual object.
The actual comment turned out to be a contact binary so we can see it here.
Uh,
that,
uh,
information was actually scooped inadvertently.
Um,
and basically the terminology,
there's two sets of terminology for the geography on Cherry,
I'm aggressive.
Manco,
there's the Egyptian,
a Rosetta theme.
And then there's of course,
this is,
everybody sees this and says this is a rubber duck.
And so there's the head,
the body,
the neck,
the head lobe in the body,
Loeb.
And people will often refer to that even in the science team meetings,
even in papers and stuff like that.
And particularly when you're talking about the landing,
um,
if you're curious,
there's actually publicly available three d models,
the highest resolution models,
not publicly available,
90 million facets.
It's based on a Cyrus data,
but like the Mathias model is publicly available.
And if you're curious,
you can print it yourself.
So you,
so what happened is that there's two pieces,
common testimonials as they're called and they came together.
It's just the right velocity and they stuck.
Um,
originally when we first got near the comment,
uh,
people thought that,
well,
no,
maybe the,
the,
that stuff in the neck is more volatiles and in a bladed off,
as we came closer to the sun,
as we kept coming closer to the sun.
But now,
based on the analysis and composition,
uh,
they believe that it's in fact a contact binary early on.
One of the scientists believe that in fact,
there were five different pieces that came together based on a texture theory.
Uh,
but you know,
there are many different opinions and that's the beauty of science.
Um,
uh,
this gives you some insight into just how textured the comet is.
So there's all these features who's boulders and so on.
And now MSL has made this quite common.
But,
uh,
at this point in time,
the Achieva selfie off of the file,
a candor filey lender at camera was actually quite unusual.
They only realize they could actually in fact do this,
um,
as they were checking out the finally lander.
And then,
believe it or not,
it's remarkably large remarks are remarkably hard to actually get the comment in
the background.
I'm very bad at selfies,
so I empathize with the OPS team.
So in November,
2014,
we delivered the lander.
This is actually from the o Cyrus camera showing the lander dropping away and
remember now,
see how stationary the lander is,
right?
It's not tumbling.
That's because it has fly wheels on it to keep it from tumbling.
Okay.
Well what happened when we actually deployed the lender?
Well,
as the,
as the lander mission manager likes to say,
we landed not once but three times.
Okay.
So if you look at this imagery,
uh,
it's quite fascinating.
You can see this is actually an image sequence that was designed to actually
search for the lender.
And so they bracketed the estimated landing time.
And you can actually see here,
uh,
I'm gonna just put it over here a little bit.
These images are about five minutes apart.
This one's really interesting because you have the touchpoint touchdown point
before and after in those slight pockmarks or the actual footprints of the
lender.
And here's the one where it's like,
if you saw this in real time,
ah,
stop.
It's hopped in.
It's going away.
Okay.
And just so you don't think that the second part of my talk is all made up,
this is the actual plan,
uh,
that came off of my laptop and that's actually showing those,
oh,
Cyrus imaging sequences in that plan as they were planned.
Okay.
So what actually happened in the file?
A landing.
Uh,
what happened is the lander hit and it turns out that the,
the comment was several orders of magnitude harder than they expected.
So there are several mechanisms that are designed to allow the finally land.
You're just secure itself to the,
to the nucleus.
First of all,
it has legs that flex,
okay?
So that should absorb some of the energy.
Second of all,
there's screws,
three screws,
one in each of the feet at the end of the legs that at contact they try and
screw in.
But the primary securing mechanism is there are two harpoons in the body of the
lander that when the contact is detected,
they fire and those are supposed to secure the lender.
Unfortunately,
what happened is the screws did not secure it.
The harpoons did not fire.
Uh,
and so the filing lander bounced.
And to make things worse,
the flight software on the file,
a lander said,
okay,
I have these flywheels,
they're eating up power,
I've now landed,
I'm going to turn them off to save energy.
And that's entirely planned.
Okay?
So now what happens is the finally landers tumbling,
right,
because of course it didn't hit perfectly flat,
uh,
and it actually tumbles for over an hour.
And so the problem here is you're landing on the head.
The original intended landing site is about here.
And I forgot to mention because it is rotating and it's rotating it between 12
hours.
I think at this time it was about 12 hours and 40 minutes.
But the rotational period of the common is varied from 1220 to 1250 as it comes
into the sun.
It changes actually.
And so it,
it basically bounced for over an hour.
So think of this as you're trying to land in mountain view.
You hit and you balance and you end up landing somewhere around Las Vegas.
Okay.
I actually probably further one 12th of the circumference,
right?
Then we got very lucky.
The next bounce we hit a very soft spot.
So after that it's only about seven minutes.
Okay.
And then eventually we landed and then now we'll talk about where we actually
landed.
So first an eye test quick.
Oh yeah,
go ahead
at,
okay.
So the question is the second bounce,
did we land on our feet?
Because we know we landed on our feet for the first bounce because that's what
everything was designed for.
Uh,
it is believed that roughly we landed on our feet because otherwise there would
have been a lot of damage to the lender.
But we don't actually know.
We have very little information.
Since you didn't know the shape of the common ahead of time,
how was the lending spot determined?
Did you get it just back and then pick it out yourself?
Very good question.
Yeah,
so we did not know the shape of the comment before we arrived.
I'll only,
all that we had was very,
very grainy,
a foot photogrammetry,
which is like basically LBO information.
So when you see these repeated lightenings and dark innings,
uh,
you can infer something about the shape and that's mainly from huddle.
But when we exited hibernation in January,
2014,
we actually entered a very close orbit to the comment in August,
2014 and we did not deploy the lander until November,
2014.
Uh,
so we were frantically mapping the comment primarily with,
uh,
with Cyrus and virtus,
the two of the main imaging instruments.
Um,
in order to choose a landing spot,
there were 10 landing spots that were proposed.
And then there was a long and heated discussion about exactly where to land
because the scientists say,
wow,
like the neck looks really interesting to me because it's got weathered terrain
in the engineers say,
what are you insane?
That's like the worst place to land.
If you're off by a little bit,
you know,
you're floating in there and the comic goes like that and kind of like smashes
you.
Um,
and then the scientists also would like to be in particular areas of
illumination and non illumination and there's a particular sweet spot,
not too hot,
you know,
kind of like the goldilocks thing,
not too hot but not too cold.
Right?
You want enough sun to power yourself but not too much sun that you,
you bake the lender.
So there was a long,
well long is four weeks a very well thought out process to choose the landing
site.
And then of course we ended up landing somewhere else.
Whatever relative velocities are we talking about putting the lender in the,
in the,
and the comment?
Very good question.
So actually the relative fly by velocities that we have on a Rosetta are
extremely low for a space mission.
So when we actually fly by the comment space,
the,
so we generally,
if that's the sun,
and this is a comment,
uh,
the spacecraft flies on the sun word side and there are a few reasons for that.
One is there are two tails that the common has.
When does the debris tail,
which is in the Anti Delta v Direction.
And then there's the [inaudible] which faces away from the Sun,
right?
That's actually what people see,
They see the ion tail.
Um,
you want to stay away from the eye on tail because you know,
all these charged particles hitting your spacecraft is kind of not cool.
Uh,
you also want to stay on the bright side of the spacecraft because all these
imaging devices over here,
they're not really seeing much,
right?
So they're not going to want to be over there.
So we fly,
we actually,
the gravity is so low that we sort of like fly like a skateboarder or used to
fly like a skateboarder.
I keep getting the tense wrong.
So we would fly these line segments like this with the camera is pointed at the
comment.
Okay.
Now then the lander itself,
uh,
the intended velocity is actually one to a fraction of a meter per second.
And then actually when the spacecraft landed,
when the orbiter landed,
uh,
again,
we're talking trying to get it around less than a meter per second.
So you're talking like a walking pace,
which is very,
very unusual for space flight.
Yes.
So during the time after the bounce,
was there any attitude control from the control system or was it just kind of
idling?
Just waiting for it?
There is no attitude control system on the lender.
So that's why you need to fly wheels.
Yeah.
Okay.
So now you guys,
uh,
here's the punchline on this slide.
So the test is who can find the lander and by the way,
think tens of thousands of these images and then poor people on the o Cyrus
team.
Like Cecile Yanno,
we're actually pouring over these for more than a year.
Um,
it's kind of,
this was the best,
uh,
this was the best one I had.
It actually would have been better if I cheated and given you one without the
lander in it.
I,
Yep.
One more shuttles,
oddly enough,
I have one that actually calls it out.
Right.
So then you can see it.
Here's the body of the lander.
Here are the legs and it's sideways in a crevasse.
Exactly.
As predicted predicted,
I say predicted because they use the telemetry data from the solar panels to
know the orientation of the lander.
Right.
They know the approximate region.
They know they can infer the orientation,
uh,
for some earth orbiting cubes.
Hats like the Ipex cube sat that I was a Pi for.
You actually build a tumble model from the periodic current data from the,
the solar panels.
So you mentioned the comment itself is about four kilometers in
diameter.
Who Right.
Some equivalent of that.
And then the orbiter was orbiting at a distance by 10.
Yeah.
During the highest activity,
we'd have to be closer to 30 kilometers,
30 to 50 kilometers.
Okay.
Um,
during the end of mission,
some of the fly buys,
in fact,
that's why they were able to find the lander.
Okay.
Uh,
some of the flybys were several kilometers.
Okay.
So like,
like I said,
my question is,
does the gravitational influence off the comedy extend that far behind?
It's,
it's everywhere where,
right.
It's just GMM over r squared.
Right.
It's just a question of how much and the,
so basically as a comment is more active,
the atmospheric gas,
the coma pushing you away from it is much more than the gravity,
so you're really not orbiting it.
That's why we were flying those line segments.
Okay.
Uh,
so this is actually,
you know,
the end of mission was,
uh,
last week.
Uh,
that's the last oh,
Cyrus image.
It's blurry.
Why is it blurry?
Because it's only taken at a distance of 20 meters.
Nobody designed the camera to take an image of that close.
It's actually designed for more like a kilometer or more.
Uh,
there's the Alice last spectrum.
That's one of the,
uh,
US instruments from Alan Stern.
It's wiry.
And then at the right,
it's actually showing the loss of signal from the spacecraft.
So we have no hope that the spacecraft is going to come back.
Why did they choose to fly it into the comment?
Uh,
there's two reasons.
One is it's going to die anyway and you can't leave it next to the comment,
right?
Because if you,
well,
it's not going to end up by the time it comes around again,
it's not going to be next to the comment.
There's just no way.
Uh,
the other thing is that enabled them to capture all kinds of unique data,
particularly for the in situ instruments.
Uh,
by going in that close a lot of the heavier species of molecules,
they don't actually get to sample them further out.
Did it serve the orbit?
Uh,
no,
because,
um,
even though the comment your EMR aggressive Manko is extremely,
let's see,
the of dense porous,
yeah.
Uh,
it's still four kilometers long,
right?
Whereas the Rosetta spacecraft is,
uh,
two meters,
right?
So we're,
we're talking quite a difference in scale right.
Also the impact philosophy is very low.
So some of the major science discoveries from Rosetta,
uh,
there's a lot of theories about the source of earth's water and some of those
theories involved commentary,
bombardment periods.
Um,
and you,
it turns out you can fingerprint the source of water by the ratio of the heavy
to light water isotopes that you see.
And so this basically shows the graph of all the different bodies that you know,
we've been able to sample from.
And you have to take some of these with a grain of salt because they remote
sensing measurements.
A Rosetta is very good and it has an in situ measurement of these isotope or
ratios.
So it's inclined to be much more accurate,
but that's the fingerprint of the ratio is different.
Uh,
as you see up here at the top,
it's far above the Blue Line,
which is earth's ratio.
So that tells you that either it was comments from the Kuyper belt and something
else mixing or something happened the water afterwards,
which is really hard.
It's really hard to change these isotopes if you're familiar with like the
production of nuclear weapons.
And stuff.
You know,
that's like one of these things.
It's very hard to do.
Um,
and uh,
so,
so this is very strong evidence that at least Kuyper belt objects can not the
primary source of Earth's water.
Another surprise was curium are brass and Manko is not magnetized.
So many theories of solar system formation had magnetism playing a major role.
There's really not much to change the magnetism of this object,
you know,
after that period.
So since it's not magnetized,
that's evidence.
Strong evidence against the fact that early solar system formation was heavily
driven by that.
All these plumes in beautiful pictures of plumes that we see,
the original mechanism that they thought that those plumes and then outgassing
happened,
it turned out to be wrong.
So they thought that photons hit,
it heats up and you see these jets and you see these plumes make sense?
Turns out that's not what happens.
What happens is the fo the photons hit the,
the uh,
water in CO2 ice.
They liberate electrons by process called photo ionization.
And those I n ionized particles then cause a subsequent reaction that involves
sublimation of those molecules directly from uh,
basically solid to gas form.
Okay.
So this is another one of the major science discoveries from uh,
Rosetta.
Another one is the detection of molecular oxygen at a comment.
Nobody thought that this would be the case.
In fact,
this,
you could argue this is the most surprising discovery.
And again this is from uh,
the cuisine instrument and in situ instrument.
So it's a very reliable,
reliable find in other fascinating discovery is cassava and other one of the in
situ instruments actually has detected organic molecules.
Okay.
So a lot of people think that amino acids,
organics came from comments,
these long carbon chains.
This is very strong evidence for that.
In other,
one of the real surprises is all of the pits that we see on the comment and some
of these are quite deep,
like hundreds of meters deep.
And it turns out what happens is as the comment heats up in this photo
ionization and everything happens,
it's actually happening.
Some of it's sub surface.
So these,
the two and h two o is being liberated subsurface and escaping to this extremely
porous comet.
And then you just have basically a collapse underneath it after too much is
liberated and that's why you see these pits.
Okay.
So again,
these are all things,
these are the reasons why we wanted to go to the comment because we learn all
these new things.
Uh,
there's a lot of other things that I don't have fun graphics about.
The finally lander Kozac and told me to instruments on it,
discovered complex carbon chains as well.
Uh,
Rosina detected glycine,
which is an amino acid.
This is an in situ detection of an amino acid at an extraterrestrial body.
That's an amazing discovery.
Okay.
And there's many,
many more.
Um,
if you're curious,
there's a link there that actually has,
if you Google it,
you can probably find it as well.
It's actually before the end of mission,
they had a series of survey talks on some of the major science discoveries.
Okay.
So that's the fun background part.
And now I'm going to talk a little bit about the AI part.
Okay.
So first I have to start out with a disclaimer.
So there are many,
many,
uh,
elements of Rosetta mission ops.
There's Rosetta,
then there's the science planning,
then the of that,
there's uplink and downlink.
Then within the uplink there's planning.
And then within that there's three phases and mission planning.
I'm going to be talking about the middle phase of mission planning because
that's where we use the different AI tools.
By the way,
this bars are obviously not to scale.
Okay?
So I got asked so many questions about this that I did a controlled experiment,
so I ain't got to ask what is Rosetta Science planning like?
And I used to just say there were a lot of phases.
Um,
and I tried to be a,
since I got all these questions,
I tried to be more precise.
So what I did is I went to my email box and I did a search on Rosetta on this
particular day on the 20th of January,
2015 and at this point in time,
all of these different planning phases we're going on.
So at that point in time we were planning the trajectory for July to October of
2015 so we're in what's called LTP.
Then that the next LTP,
which was march to June of 2015 was in what's called sk,
which is we were taking that trajectory in figuring out what campaigns we're
going to work on that for what measurement campaigns we're going to work and
what we're not going to work,
but in a fairly abstract sense.
Okay.
Like literally taking the observation campaigns from the measurement catalog and
seeing the ones that we're going to be problematic.
Then the next phase is called MTP.
That's medium term planning and then we're planning at the activity or
observation level.
So the AI was used mostly in what's called the SK in the MTP phase to rapidly
iterate among the different alternative measurement strategies.
In after that,
the planning goes into a manual planning tool called maps where they drive it
down to what's called the sequence level,
where those are the actual low level commands that get radiated to the
spacecraft.
And then those are actually delivered in,
in weekly or three and four day bundles.
And then by the way,
all a lot of these same people were at the same time how track frantically
analyzing all the data.
Before that they'd gotten a,
they were like two different special issues of science and nature that came out
even during the,
that's when you realize,
you know,
that you're on a mission that has,
high science impact.
Um,
when in November when we were deploying the lender,
we heard that there was going to be a special issue of science coming out in
January.
And it's like,
hmm.
In theory,
the primary science mission doesn't start until November.
So what are we saying here about how much science has already been done?
So this is actually a,
one of the medium term plans.
This is one of the most complicated ones that we had.
It has about 2000 observations.
Very importantly,
it has 2000 different pointings in slews of the spacecraft.
So it's Louis.
When we go change from one pointing of the spacecraft to the other,
uh,
there are about 60 active science campaigns for this month and there's also all
of the DSN.
So all of the ground communication stations,
the uplinks in the download links are also in that.
So we have to track that and actually develop that plan very rapidly.
In reality,
there's a frenzied one week where we really take that plan from what's called sk
in the MTP.
And after that it's very,
very hard to substantively change it.
So why is it hard to build this plan?
Uh,
well,
the number one reason for Rosetta is because of geometry.
I mentioned that we have the spacecraft and we're flying around like this.
Well,
the exact view in geometry that we have really is going to impact the kind of
measurement you can take.
And so in remote sensing,
we have what's called the target observer,
illumination geometry.
So the illumination is the sun.
So let's assume it's back there.
These lights.
The target is someplace on the nucleus.
Let's just assume that for now.
And so if I'm here or here,
it's going to look very different.
If I'm looking for plumes,
I want to phase angle,
let's say 130 to 150 degrees.
That means I want to be looking at the comment backlit.
So all the images of plumes that you see,
the comment is all black.
Okay?
Uh,
if I'm looking at the surface,
I want the illumination behind me,
right?
But there's a slight problem.
Turns out the plus z deck is where the camera is an imaging instruments are the
minuses he deck is where the fuel tank is.
Um,
we don't like the fuel tank to get hot for obvious reasons.
So we can't literally go over what's called the sub solar point.
That's why we fly in these different lines segments,
but very rarely go straight across.
Okay.
And by the way,
this comment is rotating at the same time the spacecraft is flying,
it's trajectory.
So you need to be able to identify all of the correct geometries.
And so we actually compute all those.
Extract them.
And that's really what we're searching and we are searching in time,
but we have to extract all the appropriate geometry.
So we actually reason about all these constraints,
all of those vectors,
all the combinations of those vectors.
If it's,
if there's a vector and there's an angle,
probably some scientist is interested in it.
And this is an example of our planning around MTP nine which is the lender
delivery.
And this is an actual observation where a,
for the breach CEO who's the virtus Pi says we want to image with a phase angle
of greater than 80 degrees but be within 15 kilometers of the nucleus.
And the interesting thing is those are the different times that we can do that.
And then maybe you'll get scheduled there.
And he said,
well how come this time did,
didn't get scheduled?
And those are the kinds of questions that we have to answer in the different
scheduling process.
Okay.
The pointing can actually get quite complicated that Alyse spectra that they
talked about,
that instrument is actually a slip.
So that red part indicates the slit in the,
this particular observation,
they want to take scans across the nucleus.
And this is an observation that's very near and dear to my heart because there's
a very similar instrument called you've is on Europa and we want to do these
scans across the Europa Moon.
When we fly in and we want to scan for fresh plumes that again we can detect
spectrally and then if we find a fresh plume,
we want to target that observation on that fly by without the ground in the
loop.
Why do we want to do this?
If you have a plume and you don't catch it until the next time the spacecraft
comes around,
which for Europa is probably 30 days,
those complex organics from that subsurface ocean,
they may already be broken down from there were harsh radiation environment.
Okay,
so that your chance of detecting life or the precursors of life there depends on
being able to do that quickly.
So in this case,
we want to do these skills,
these different scans up and down,
and we have to combine this with all kinds of other problems.
Like,
we don't know exactly where the spacecraft is.
So there's some pointing year.
So you actually have to scan past the edge of the nucleus.
And these get quite complicated.
This is actually showing a morose skin,
which looks like Alice.
So we're sweeping up and down here and then it's going to stop in the middle and
there it stops and then it goes on.
Why did that happen?
Why did it stop?
Well,
it turns out this is a combination of merger of two different instrument
observations.
Or Cyrus wanted to take a picture of the nucleus.
So what we did is we have to plan it.
So you take this picture of the nucleus and then the scan happens to be at that
point.
Okay.
And that's how you try and operate the spacecraft more quickly.
So the pointing is very,
very important.
I already mentioned that you know,
you have to deal with other geometric constraints like the fuel tank.
You also can't point the instruments too close to the sun.
That's not a good thing.
And then there are different pointing tradeoffs.
So as we're flying around,
the spacecraft is designed so that it goes sideways with the solar panels
cutting through the gas while the imaging instruments are pointed at the
nucleus.
And by the way,
all those in situ instruments were all those science and nature papers came
from.
They're pointed in what's called the Ram Direction,
the Delta v Direction.
So everybody's happy until some imaging scientist says,
you know,
if I'm in close and I look out,
I can measure the gas cloud very precisely.
So they like that.
But then all the in situ instrument people said,
what you're screwing with my data,
you're totally messing with my data.
So what do we have to do?
We have to measure,
we have to measure how much of the gas cloud,
how many particles are going to be hitting the detectors at various points in
time.
And for some of the instruments they need a background signal.
So you don't get any data for the first 15 minutes after you SLU.
So the short story here is you really don't want to point away the z deck away
from Nadir when you're near.
And then how far off you point in how close you are when you,
how close to the nucleus yard when you point those are trades.
So we did a series of trade studies on how much science we would be losing of
each type.
And so that's one of the advantages of having the automated planting system.
You can do all these trade studies are easily,
you also have to optimize different kinds of pointings.
Um,
if I'm sitting here and I'm,
the son is back there and I'm looking at the nucleus and I have what's called
the inertial target,
that's a target that's not moving with the comment.
So let's suppose it's a guide star.
It's in the corner there and the corner of the room there.
If I'm on this side of the comment and I slew over there,
it's a very small SLU.
it's almost 180 degrees,
right?
Because we have 30 meters solar panels on the Rosetta spacecraft.
It's not very agile.
That 30 minutes,
that 180 degrees slew would take you over 20 minutes.
So we act to actually group the different initial targets when they are shorter
distances.
Okay.
And then there's this other problem.
We have a the antenna,
if we slew too quickly that Gimbal,
the antenna can no longer pointed earth and we are downlinking data all the
time.
And that's because we don't have a lot of power.
So our data rates not that high.
So all of these pointing things really,
really flow into the planning problem.
In other thing is we have structured observation.
So this is an example of one of the most complicated structured observations,
all those beautiful pictures and three d models that you see of the commentary
on grass,
the Manko,
those are from oh Cyrus maps.
So what did they do?
They use the rotation of the nucleus and then the stripe up and down it
longitudinally.
Okay.
And so that's how you construct a map of the entire nucleus.
What does that mean?
That means over 12 or 13 hours,
you want a series of images and each image will take us here in the amount of
time.
That's exactly what's being scheduled here.
But note that the spacing is not perfect because there are different operations
constraints where you can't get the spacecraft.
So to an AI person,
I would say this is it.
Multi objective optimization problem.
These are all of the different science concerns that Holger Spherex who'd be the
oh Cyrus Pi would bring up.
He would say,
well,
in this month I asked for three groupings,
three of these mappings,
but really,
can I have four?
Um,
and by the way,
I want those evenly spaced throughout that month.
Oh,
in all of those groupings,
I want all 12 images.
If you give me 10 of them,
then that's not as good as an overall schedule.
And within that grouping,
they were all supposed to be evenly spaced.
Right?
Then there's this other fun thing.
They navigate the spacecraft twice per week,
every fourth in third day alternatingly oddly enough,
right after the navigate the space craft,
they know better where it is.
When they know better where the spacecraft is,
that means you're pointing years lower.
Shockingly,
everybody wants to observe when the pointing years lower,
right?
And then the distance to target is also changing.
As I mentioned,
as you fly by,
you fly these line segments,
you get closer and you get further away,
there's an optimal distance at target.
And furthermore,
you don't want variation in the distance to target across these groupings.
The local time is changing as the nucleus rotates.
So basically when you get off cadence,
the local time of your stripes will now change.
That's not good for the mapping.
And then the emission angle changes in addition,
because we're not just staying at the equator because as we go north and south,
that emission angle is now changing.
So the way I would phrase this is it's a multi objective optimization problem.
And by the way,
we don't have the objective function and the scientists will just tell you when
you're,
um,
until they change their mind,
right?
So there's actually researchers who are interested in formulating this actually
as one of these oracle based objective,
you know,
trying to infer the objective function.
So there's some interesting work going on there.
By the way,
the scientists also have to interleave all of this with all kinds of engineering
activities.
So the navigation of the spacecraft,
firing a thrusters and so on.
So in that previous example for a Cyrus,
and this is a different example for Alice,
we can't have the Alis covers open within 30 minutes of a thrust you're firing
cause that would contaminate the instrument.
So that's an example of an engineering constraint.
And then arguably one of the most complicated constraints is downlink
management.
So as we acquire all of this data,
it's filling these buffers.
There's 14 to 18 of them depending on how you count the engineering buffers and
we stream the data into them and we have to downlink it without overflowing it.
Otherwise you just lost that data that you worked so hard to get.
And so that's actually a very hard problem,
particularly when we're doing these mapping campaigns,
we actually have to empty the buffers.
Then we frantically downlink massively.
We get all these down links to downlink that data as we're acquiring it.
And still,
by the way,
at the end is you can see here we're completely full,
right?
So this is actually one of the major areas of automation here.
Okay.
So where is the AI scheduling?
Well,
it turns out all those constraints that I talked about pretty much are modeled
in Aspen and we have to actually track them and enforce them.
Okay.
So there are all these science constraints cause all these health constraints of
the space craft and some of them are hard constraints and then some of them are
soft constraints.
Generally speaking,
we attempt to satisfy the soft constraints,
but we don't unfortunately do this multi objective optimization.
Maybe the next mission.
Uh,
and then how do we search?
We actually take the,
we take the constraints and we break them into two parts.
The first part are relatively static.
We solve them and then we use that as a guide to solving the dynamic
constraints.
And then that's where we really have to do the heavy duty search.
What are the static constraints?
Well,
once we have the trajectory,
most of those geometric constraints are now static,
right?
Because the geometry,
the relative geometry of the spacecraft and the nucleus,
it's not changing.
Or at least if it is,
you're not able to know that it's going to change.
However,
some of the other things are dynamic.
The resources are dynamic because when you place a few observations,
they're consuming resources that the other,
the other uh,
observations would need.
What else is dynamic?
Some of the geometry,
like where you're pointing and seeing,
you know,
how long the fuel tank has been in the sun.
So we actually take all the static parts of the problem,
we extract them,
then we search in,
solve that problem,
and then we use that as a guide for the dynamic search.
Okay.
And what does this,
what does this really look like?
This looks like what we have at the bottom here.
We have a set of observations.
We look for gaps in the schedule,
usually in pointing,
and then we try and insert the observations in places where they satisfy the
constraint.
And so this is actually showing what that really looks like.
These green intervals here are the different constraints.
There's about 25 of them that we modeled different feasibility windows.
And then this is literally an animation of the search as it's trying the
different combinations of the groupings.
And if your eyesight is really good,
you can see that these in fact the solutions that the schedulers come up with,
at least for now.
Uh,
so this is basically what I said.
We take a satisficing temporal solution and we take all the static constraints,
we compile them in their constraint network form.
We take that and we search in that for all the dynamic constraints.
We actually compute all of the validity intervals,
all those green and white constraint intervals.
In theory,
you only have to winnow them down,
but we compute them all.
Why do we do that?
Because the scientists will always come back to us and say,
why didn't my observation gets scheduled here?
And so you have to go and say,
well here are the four constraints that you told me and this is how they're
violated.
And that particular point,
the downlink scheduling,
we actually enforce after we scheduled the observations.
And that's because there are other triggers that the schedule is not allowed to
pull.
But the operations team can pull to say,
oh,
those eight images,
those are now video images in order to make the schedule work.
And then finally,
originally when we deployed the scheduler,
there was squeaky wheel optimization around this whole loop.
What does that mean?
That means you take the highest priority observations that didn't get in,
you increment their priority and you try it again.
As we got into operations,
what ended up happening is the operations engineer became that optimization
loop.
Okay.
Because it was faster for the people who are very smart to tweak the priorities
and try and get whatever result that would,
you know,
the,
the best of their knowledge that the scientists would be happy with.
The second part of the scheduling,
the downlink management,
this is just a different blow up of,
of it.
And you can see there are these different buffers that are being tracked.
And so the scientists and the engineers would actually take the solution that we
would find in our heuristic search.
And then in some cases they might try and tweak it,
but actually you fairly rarely because it's actually a very hard problem to
solve at the MTP level.
You can think of it as a 300 variable,
mostly linear programming problem.
Um,
what are examples of the plan sizes we looked at?
I already kind of gave you some examples of this.
They are on the ballpark of 2000 observations.
Those would expand out into tens of thousands of constraints that have to be
checked.
One of the most significant contributions we've made to the mission is during
the land or delivery phase,
we had to manage multiple contingencies and then the engineering team was
changing what they were going to do in order to like,
correct the navigation and so on.
So at one point in time and there we had three different contingencies times and
other two contingencies of land or abort.
Uh,
and we would take what's called the PTSL,
which is the engineering plan and we had to turn it around within hours.
So they would completely change the engineering plan and we would have to Redo
the science plan around it in about an hour.
Um,
how did all of this workout?
Uh,
it worked out quite well.
before we actually got to the comment,
we did two sets of deliveries of science plans for about eight months each.
Each one covered about eight months,
and this was used to assess the different science campaigns,
how feasible they were to operate on the orbiter,
and significant changes had to be made from this.
There are two campaigns that it turned out of the 350 or so science campaigns
that in the original forum would've taken three sevenths of the free observation
time of the entire mission.
So obviously that's not going to happen.
So they had to be redesigned.
The Rosetta spacecraft woke up in January,
2014.
Uh,
aspen was used in this,
uh,
as I said,
this midterm activity planning,
um,
uh,
into the escort phase,
including multiple contingencies until about,
um,
spring of 2015.
And so a total of about 28 MTPs were delivered using aspen.
However,
what happened in the spring of 2015 is,
uh,
the spacecraft was flying too close to the nucleus and the dust cloud blinded to
star trackers.
It actually was a very dangerous event.
It took them three days.
Do we gain control of the spacecraft?
We easily could have lost the spacecraft then.
So based on that,
they decided they would no longer have a plan,
a preplanned,
deliberative trajectory,
like six months in advance,
even with the two contingencies.
And instead what they decided is there would be a notional trajectory and they
would just try and fly as close to the common as possible.
And so what that meant is a lot of the pre planning and optimization that aspen
was involved in was no longer possible.
And so they actually took the constraints that were implemented and Aspen and
basically forced them into the preceding and following phase.
In other words,
in the maps.
And then actually the LTP,
believe it or not,
it's even excel spreadsheet where they enforce the constraints.
Uh,
and so that's,
that was the planning process that they went on with for the remainder of the
mission,
which is a little more than a year.
Uh,
the data management system,
uh,
d Alec was continue is continued to be used and it actually was used until the
end of mission.
So that part was still automated scheduling.
So let me just finish up here.
What's next?
Well,
we would like to take these same technologies and put them on board the
spacecraft.
Uh,
this is actually a video that we used,
um,
that's running a CMU that's showing a simulation.
It's actually uses Rosetta data and it shows us smart fly by.
So instead of pre planning out these campaigns,
where we'd like to do is take a whole bunch of oh Cyrus images and look for
plumes and that those are the large boxes in the yellow line that you see is not
a laser where we're shooting the,
the nucleus.
It's in fact showing,
uh,
a small field of view instrument like Miro that's imaging the base of a plume
that's been discovered in the large imagery in here.
You can see the fly by so fast that the spacecraft can't actually keep the
nucleus interview.
Why would we like to do something like this?
Because right now we don't have any narrow field of view imagery of those
specific point targets.
Why?
Because because it's a narrow field of view instrument.
What are the chances you're going to actually get the base of the blue?
There are other things you'd like to do,
like trace,
the edge of the plume.
All of those things are possible if you have the onboard autonomy.
And just so you don't think that this is completely made up,
these are actually some of the initial algorithms we have shown.
The ability to track the plumes,
actually track them across flame,
across frames and actually tracking them across frames is a very powerful
technique because the plumes actually persist over time.
Uh,
there's,
there's similar techniques where we want to do this in an earth observing a
autonomous system where you would have to re task just within minutes.
And then,
um,
the most exciting thing lately is what's called Ocean worlds.
Uh,
we now believe that there are underneath large ice caps,
ocean worlds at Europa,
Enceladus,
Triton,
and even Pluto.
Okay.
And these are some of the primary locations where we might find extant life in
our solar system.
And that's because we have liquid,
we have energy sources,
we have gradients,
or we believe we have all of those.
So we'd like to go to Europa,
melt our way,
or burn our way through the ice cap,
deploy a submersible.
We don't know what this underwater ocean looks like,
but we know if we have a submersible,
it will have a NASA logo on it.
Evidently.
Uh,
and then this is a a little bit inaccurate.
So because the,
the scientist would say,
oh,
let's go look at that water ice boundary.
The engineers would say,
ah,
pointy,
sharp object.
Right?
Um,
so more likely you would sample from a plume,
from a hydrothermal vent because this is one of the most likely sources of life.
In fact,
there's a guy on my team right now who's on a German icebreaker,
the polar stern at 85 north investigating with called the Karasik Massif,
which is an Arctic hydrothermal vent,
uh,
where they're searching for new life forms right there.
And then just if that wasn't exciting enough for you,
the ultimate challenge is in interstellar mission.
You'd have like a 50 or 60 year cruise to go to the closest star when you go
there.
The One way light time is four and a half years.
So you're probably not joysticking that spacecraft.
It's pretty much autonomous submersible.
I talked about would have to be autonomous for let's say 10,
20,
30 days.
This is 80 years of autonomy.
So,
uh,
for going wormholes or something like that,
this is how it's gotta be.
Um,
JPL has a long line of,
you know,
AI based,
uh,
autonomous systems.
Uh,
we're very proud of them.
Um,
I was actually reviewing this talk just yesterday night and that's when I had to
change the Rosetta from the Yellow Fund to the White Fund,
which means it's no longer operational.
Uh,
but we're very proud that a lot of these spacecraft,
we are the operational system used to command them.
We have flight software on board,
both MSL and Murnau.
Uh,
we have the software that schedules the deep space network,
all the communications antennas.
So Ai is very much alive and well at JPL and NASA.
So just to summarize here,
I hope you've all come away with the understanding that for a complex mission,
like Rosetta,
the scheduling of the mission is very hard.
That's behind the scenes to enable the science.
There's a lot of different constraints and a lot of constraints that are
articulated hard engineering constraints as well as ones that are not
articulated.
Um,
they're competing science campaigns.
Most of the constraints or soft,
the typical planning process for one of these missions would be very interactive
and incremental.
What are the implications for Ai Research?
Well,
first of all,
we can take heart that AI is being used in such a big mission like this.
But to me the lessons are,
a lot of these basics of AI maybe aren't so sexy anymore,
but they are considered,
you know,
like in your first year,
second AI course,
you already learned about them.
Constrained enforcement,
constraint propagation,
uh,
horistic search.
These are all important for scheduled generation,
but almost more importantly,
problem analysis,
observation campaign in constraint analysis.
And in this particular use case,
the scheduler is not automating everything.
It's amplifying the human's ability to explore more alternatives,
explore more of the,
um,
schedule,
search space.
And one thing I would say that's very important here is it's actually in these
cases it's more important to be able to understand what the scheduler did.
Then,
you know,
maybe a 0.5% better solution.
So just a different acknowledgements.
I always have to start off with acknowledging my wife because she allowed me to
work on this project.
It was a three year project that turned out to be a five year project and
project with no operations that turned out to have a lot of operations including
one week a month in Madrid for the primary phase Freelander delivery.
Uh,
so I have to thank,
my wife were still being with me through all of this.
Um,
aspen is a joint NASA Jpl Isa effort have to acknowledge all the wonderful
collaborators that we've had at east side and some of them were working with.
Even now on the juice mission,
uh,
we have to acknowledge the larger team in of course,
our technology sponsors.
And finally a tragically last year we lost our,
uh,
US was at a project scientist,
Claudia Alexander.
Um,
and uh,
in memory to her,
uh,
I always note this as a,
in all my talks,
he was very,
very influential and science.
She's also the former,
uh,
Galileo project manager and very much a stem advocate.
And role model for women in science and should be commended and remembered,
uh,
with that.
Thank you all for your attention.
[inaudible]
you mentioned not having this objective function for what you're doing,
is that mainly because it's such a difficult problem space or is that also a
difficulty in assigning relative weights?
Are merits to different science tasks?
Uh,
I would say yes to both of them.
So it's also the nature of the mission is very interdisciplinary and there are
so many diverse instruments,
so we specific problems,
particularly NASA that we do know the objective function.
So for example,
if you're mapping the planet,
then there are some measures of coverage that you can assess and these are
quantitative,
so it's more like,
you know,
if you're scheduling your production line,
you know what your quality metrics are,
you want to produce as many widgets as possible.
Um,
but still,
uh,
even that's quite complicated.
There's a mission called [inaudible],
which is a interferometric synthetic aperture radar,
um,
mission that's jointly between JPL,
NASA and the Indian Space Agency.
And so they have these different coverage metrics,
but it turns out there's about 50 different science campaigns and each one has
its own coverage in metric.
And so one is monitoring glaciers and the other is,
you know,
looking at earthquake faults and another.
And so when you look at the combination of all of them,
well then it's not quite so clear what your objective function is.
But there I think you have a fighting chance,
uh,
on a mission.
Like Rosetta,
it's to interdisciplinary.
Certain things just have to meet negotiated.
So really you have to look at it as a,
what we call an IAA problem,
intelligence amplification,
not really a completely automated problem.
So you mentioned several times,
uh,
flying and like a line segment.
So I was curious about that and why,
you know,
it seems like flying,
like in curves around that would be more fuel efficient,
uh,
except you're not,
not,
you're optimizing for a lot of things and fuel efficiency would be one of them.
Um,
but you're also flying the segment that's the easiest to navigate.
So by navigate,
we mean predict,
control an estimate.
Uh,
and so when we're,
uh,
was that as a chemical spacecraft,
so it's not like I am propulsion so it's not firing it's engines continuously.
So with the line segments you basically get to the end,
you orient and you fire,
then you do a correction burn and then you don't fire until the other end of the
line segment.
So flying a continuous curve might be better for some reasons including viewing
geometry,
but it would be a lot more stress on the navigators.
Thanks.
So also you'd have to be very careful because as I said,
they try and fly to slice the solar panels through the coma,
particularly when we were married helion and August,
2015 so doing that.
Exactly.
Um,
would be exciting,
let's say.
Uh,
cause it would depend on the accuracy of your coma model,
um,
cause you'd be continuously varying the Delta v direction.
So I would say that I'm not disagreeing with anything you're saying,
but there are a lot of constraints there.
You know,
did the interstellar mission,
you mentioned the software that runs that,
I've taught them mostly what you don't like.
What would be that major modules or building blocks of something like that.
Wow.
Okay.
Really putting me on the spot here.
Um,
I'm not sure we know,
uh,
there are advocates who say,
well,
okay,
that has to be some kind of very general evolving,
you know,
spacecraft evolving software and whatever.
I don't know how you guys feel here at Google,
but at least for me,
I'm like,
yeah,
not quite yet.
They're in comfortable with that because we're talking about,
you know,
like a many trillions of dollars,
probably to,
to conduct such a mission like that.
Um,
so you want to,
you want to have quite a bit of confidence that it's going to work.
Um,
so I would focus more on traditional software,
but really the question is when you get there,
you have so many open choices,
what are the planets look like?
Which plan is do you go see first knowing full well that when you entered orbit
around one planet,
you have enough resources to then go visit another planet where it really to
look at it in context,
you know,
you got to orbit it flying by is,
just enough to get you really curious.
Right?
So to make an analogy to Rosetta,
the reason why there were all these misconceptions about comments is they've
flown by the call,
this the golden era of comment missions because depending on how you count,
there's been,
you know,
half a dozen to maybe even 10 comment missions.
But those are all flybys of like a day or two.
This was two years at this comment.
Completely different ballgame.
So when you get to this other solar system,
uh,
to me I would set the bar low.
I would say the smart software has to just do better than the dumb software
alternative.
So it has to pick a planet,
get to orbit around it,
map it,
search for signs of life,
look for different virus signatures.
But there's even quite a bit of controversy about what those signs of life would
be.
Right.
I mean,
I welcome any inputs from any of you guys.
If you got to a planet and you knew nothing about it,
what would you look for?
It's a really hard question.
So does any of the Ai software have a uh,
Theresa its heritage back to the remote agent?
I would say not directly.
Um,
but certainly the remote agent was the first time that,
you know,
we were able to fly a planner.
I would say the fact that there's a planner and exact onboard is similar.
So it's still in this generic view of like a three layer architecture.
Uh,
but the individual things have changed a lot.
So,
uh,
the planning that we use as much more incremental planning and not batch
planning.
And then when we talk about flight software,
which is a more direct comparison,
uh,
to,
you know,
remote agent because remote remote Asian was flight software,
not ground software.
Uh,
I would say the main differences is our,
that we now emphasize being very close to the science.
So a very big part of that timeline that I showed you a is that we have all
kinds of image processing,
software clustering software,
very detailed instrument analysis,
software for spectral and mixing.
If you guys are familiar with remote sensing,
so it's figuring out the constituency of the individual elements that you're
looking at from the spectral lines.
All those things are now very much what we do.
Please join me in thanking [inaudible] Steve
[inaudible].